nous sommes en plein cœur de la riche et
pourtant ici comme dans le reste du
département on vendange un très bon
raisin très très beau des belles grappes
et très sucré des vignes et des
immeubles en toile de fond cette idée on
la doit à quelques amis qui ont voulu
réhabiliter le passé viticole de la
ville ainsi depuis 2003 300 pieds de
vignons ont été plantés chez les
particuliers une association a même été
créée on avait sur le territoire de la
riche c'est les anciennes Varennes
on avait beaucoup de jardiniers et ces
jardiniers pour délimiter leur
territoire il faisait des petits murets
et long de ces murs couraient des vignes
l'origine est là et à l'époque de Louis
X les habitants produisaient déjà
eux-mêmes leurs vins avant de soif comme
on dit rendu possible par la plantation
de treilles ces vignes qui courent le
long des habitations et c'est ce même
vain que les Larry choix d'aujourd'hui
produisent nous sommes chez Joël un des
80 membres de l'association chez lui
deux pieds de vigne ont été plantés et
c'est avec une grande satisfaction que
ce jeune retraité s'apprête à détacher
les grappes et c'est le côté
convivialité pour faire du vin
et puis faire la fête avec les amis et
les copains voilà c'est juste une
production d'associations
juste pour le plaisir c'est pour le
loisir et puis bon c'est très joli en
plus les feuillages est très beau le
raisin est ensuite emmené au pressoir
communal un rituel désormais immuable
quel tout le monde assiste les grelots
et Pinot Noir sont broyés le breuvage
coule avant d'être goûté et enfin
entreposer pour produire dans 15 jours
de la Bernage et dans deux mois du 20
novembre l'an passé 300 bouteilles ont
pu être remplies et distribués aux
membres de l'association